there's a quote I loved that I think a
lot of people now can see in our
country's politics and you do have some
ideas on how we can get Beyond this
um so this is a quote by Gerard who who
inspired much of the book human beings
fight not because they are different but
because they are the same and in their
attempts to distinguish themselves have
made themselves into enemy twins human
doubles in reciprocal violence that that
quote would piss a lot of people off I'm
sure yeah because who wants to think
that they may be more like the very
people that they think are the problem
you know nobody wants to think that but
we we often are more alike I mean in in
World mythology there's almost always in
almost every culture there is a story
about twins usually identical twins
involved in Conflict you know in the
Bible in the Book of Genesis alone there
are five stories of sibling rivalry and
Renee Gerard looked at this phenomenon
you know like okay they're Miss but why
is there's usually something true right
you're getting at something true in
human nature and the truth that he
thought they were getting at is that
we're kind of terrified of similarity
and we often hate that which
um is kind of like us right
um in in this that plays out in in funny
small ways you know like I don't know
somebody walks into the office with the
same exact haircut that we just got
wearing the same clothes you know it's
like it's a little weird we don't like
that at all
um and we also tend to see in other
people
um sometimes the very things that we
don't like in ourselves and Gerard also
said be careful
be careful who you make your enemies
because you become like them and part of
why you become like them is because
you're so focused on them you imitate
them often in negative ways you know
that they become the biggest influence
on our lives and I think this is a
there's a really important lesson to be
learned here in U.S politics it causes
us to miss out on a path forward
um on a way out of the predicament
because we're so focused in on each
other and the image that I like to use
are two people that are you know I like
to think of people standing shoulder to
shoulder looking out at the future right
um because if they're just standing face
to face in a standoff they can't see the
way out and
um one small silly little story I'll
never forget when I was a kid and I I
thought of this story after I started
writing this book I remember seeing
these two dogs behind a baseball field
fence near my house and the two dogs
were in a standoff and they both were
kind of barking and wanting to get on
the other side of the fence and they
would look at each other and they were
kind of on the verge of fighting hair
standing knob tails and one of them
would kind of try to walk away to get
away and then you would turn around and
look back and neither one of them could
get away from the other one and all
either one of them needed to do is just
ignore the other one and walk around
fence like 50 yards away but they were
unable to do that because their focus
was was completely on each other and
there's a lesson in there when it comes
to rivalry and conflict and the sort of
the memetic force the centripetal force
that holds us inside of a system or an
institution or a way of thinking and
we're not able to transcend it because
our arrival is completely dominating our
mindset yeah you you catalog 15
techniques that you use to try and
transcend those kinds of destructive
Dynamics uh
let's have you share one or two so
people can have a sense as to making
this uh positive and something that they
can recognize then maybe get Beyond sure
there's a couple very simple things you
know one of them that you could do today
if you wanted
and that's you know quite simply naming
who important models in your life have
been and who important models in your
life today might be and actually writing
them down you know there's something
powerful about about naming models of
desire and be careful because models of
Desire are not the same thing as role
models
um models of Desire are people that in
some some sense affect what we want so
they're modeling a desire and not just a
role
um you know my my accountant is a role
model of uh accuracy and organization
for me I have no idea what the guy
desires so he's not he's not a he's not
a model of desire for me so you know put
them all about positive and negative
right on a piece of paper and gain some
clarity you'll probably remember some
tomorrow or the next day and that helps
gain some you know naming things gives
us some power over them or over what
they do to us this is psychology 101
naming your emotions same concept here
and then the other thing is and this one
is a little bit harder the one of the
most positive things ever happened to me
in my life in fact where I learned about
memetic desire and Renee Gerard in the
first place was when I went when I went
on a silent Retreat and
a silent Retreat if even if it's for a
half a day or a day we'll do some pretty
scary things to you in a good way like
things will kind of like bubble up to
the surface that you didn't even know
were there once the noise of technology
and everything recedes
so I think you could start very small
with this you know even even a couple of
hours no technology put everything away
and
see what desires bubble up to the
surface because my theory and what I've
experienced in my own life is that the
thick desires that I have the things
that are really important to me are
often just completely crowded out by the
thin mimetic desires the short-term
things that I want and if I spend the
rest of my life just trying like chasing
the thin mimetic desires and not even
letting the thick ones bubble up to the
surface I won't even know that they're
there you know it's like leaves that are
covering them up so
that's not an easy thing to do those are
just there's 15 in the book those are
those are two small ones I get into a
lot more detail about how to do those
things but I think that those are those
are just easy ways to start
bang up new guests thank you